[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants au nom nounours
arrête de gesticuler ainsi qui va faire
chavirer notre nuage au patron juste un
peu d'exercice pour entretenir ma femme
comme les grands champions au fond le
seul prénom je vais te montrer comment
font les grands boxeurs à la télévision
et le retard il n'est ni mon petit
nicolas on ne boxe pas l'état c'est un
sport il aurait chassé fin ça me tirait
les cheveux roses muntari est à moi je
préfère jouer à la poupée voilà oui
heureusement que j'appelais quart voit
la boxe ça me connaît
j'ai été un athlète un champion
encore un film how d'abord une bonne
position deux bombes tout en souplesse
son lot de défis ou non vers ce train de
terminer athlètes tu fais dodo note
bien sûr que je suis pas natale
tu vas voir petit boxeur de requins du
tout notre âge panon seconde où j'ai
fait venir à la salle de bain je ne fais
pas de natation je donne une leçon aux
prix bas
oui oui oui mon petit naseaux pour le
vieux boxeur je ne boxerai plus jamais
avec lui à l'ong auxerre assieds toi je
veux tu es tu as peu d'oxygène mais ça
ne pique pas au mois presque pas
bougez pas on s'applique aux plus aussi
quand il te ton frère pas preneur je
suis très fâché ou leur à matt rusch ma
petite truie
je me suis trompé jamais d'alcool à 90°
ces malades de médicaments piquant sur
les notes pour floor et toi c'est mal
est de jouer à la boxe est un sport de
brutes à fin du dos est encore tout
jeune fille berceau du marché ça je ne
suis pas content du tout ou pas de trou
tu es un gros nigaud nounours la boxe
n'est pas un jeu pour les petits enfants
se finit pas trop je ne boxerai plus
jamais ce flou j'espère bien car ce soir
tu as donné le mauvais exemple
bonne nuit les enfants allez vite vous
coucher et ne fait surtout pas comme
nounours et nicolas à demain faute pour
[Musique]